next thing you know you're throwing off
the show you drop out of school your mom
takes you out and you're living behind a
dumpster luckily for zendaya
her career went in the exact opposite
direction
you know you've made it big when
everyone across the globe knows who you
are
by just your first name drake adele
madonna
and now zendaya since her days as a
disney star she's become a huge
influence on gen z
and is one of the hottest names in
hollywood but it wasn't without huge
transformations that zendaya was able to
take over the acting music and fashion
industry so how exactly did she make it
to the top we are taking you right back
to this celeb's beginnings
and we promise after this you'll never
be able to look at zendaya the same
again
i want to do what makes me happy for as
long as it makes me happy
believe it or not zendaya came from a
pretty ordinary family her parents were
teachers who did their best when it came
to helping their extremely shy daughter
achieve her hollywood dreams so how
exactly did young zendaya transform
herself from a timid little
girl who had to repeat kindergarten to
the disney star we were all first
introduced to
well being teachers her parents thought
introducing her to the arts and
auditions at a young age would help her
get over her social troubles
and it obviously worked because at just
12 years old
she landed herself a role in a selena
gomez music video
and a short while after landed the role
of rocky in disney's hit show
shake it up we watched her transform
right before our eyes during her time on
the disney channel
not only as an actor and dancer but as a
singer author
and overall style icon she's talked
about how coming into hollywood with her
dad
they both knew nothing about makeup or
clothing or the overall fashion industry
but after making the right connections
we watched her emerge as zendaya coleman
disney's newest sweetheart
to watch out here comes queen zendaya in
a matter of a few years
things happened a lot faster for me
because i had my goal i was ready to go
and i was a new face her new spotlight
also gave her the opportunity to start a
music career with her new look in clutch
she released her first self-titled album
in 2013 with hollywood records
remember her banger replay she was still
just a teen when it was released but
despite the newfound fame
zendaya made sure she stayed true to her
heart projecting kindness and helping
her fans on their journey through life
when she released her book between you
and me she said she wrote the book
in order to help girls through the
tougher parts of between years
and help them appreciate the fun parts
this is no doubt when her influence on
gen z
began to really grow she became a best
friend to millions around the world
right now i need for you young people i
need you guys to be educated we now know
though that zendaya's first few years on
the disney channel were anything but
magical
her co-star bella thorne has spoken
about how they were put in an
unfortunate position
when they felt they were competing
against one another you have to admit
though
four frenemies see what we did there
they did pull off the best friend vibes
on screen
perfectly despite the tension so kudos
to them but zendaya knew that if she was
going to stay on the disney channel
things had to change so she took charge
accepting the lead role on casey
undercover came with a lot of conditions
for disney
zendaya would be one of the producers
and she knew it was time to add a fight
for diversity to her platform
it was important to her that disney
become more diverse especially being a
person of color herself
she told insider that it's hard to watch
a series as a child
and not see anyone who looks like you
her advocacy for equality even impacted
the fashion industry
in a huge way when she attended the 2015
oscars
she made a point to style her hair in
dreadlocks in order to remind people of
color
that our hair is good enough she faced
some pretty hard criticism but took it
in stride and educated her fans like the
queen she is
and just like that her bold statement at
the oscars sparked an entire movement
that even had
the company mattel designing barbies
after her red carpet look
i wanted to this to be a positive
experience people to learn from it
people to grow from it
leaving the disney channel always comes
with a stigma attached to it will she go
rogue
will she ruin her image is she the next
lindsay lohan and the pressure doesn't
just disappear overnight in fact
the proof is there just by taking a look
at how differently the media treats
zendaya
and bella thorne but after leaving the
disney channel zendaya made sure she
stayed grounded and continued to fight
for the career she wanted without
letting go of her beliefs
in 2016 she released her very own
fashion line
deya by zendaya that truly stood for
everything she believed
once again she took her fight for
diversity and let it influence her image
in the fashion
world not only was the line extremely
affordable but also
every product was unisex and offered in
size 0 to 22.
i mean what we're only really now
starting to hear about more inclusivity
in the fashion world
zendaya was years ahead and it
definitely gave her a foot in the door
when it came to her career in fashion
and beauty
confidence is the best i think you can
literally rock a trash bag if you have
confidence
during her time on kc undercover and
beyond she did return back to her
musical roots releasing more albums and
starring in music videos with celebs
like taylor swift and beyonce
but after starting to land huge
blockbuster roles she decided to take a
step
back from the music industry she also
admitted that the music industry just
wasn't her vibe anymore
and it made her lose a bit of passion
but that loss of passion didn't stop her
from her next glow up both physically
and career-wise i'm not pretending to be
something that i'm not
landing her role in the spider-man films
might have been a huge step out of her
comfort zone but transforming into the
character of mj
apparently wasn't all that difficult she
had been a huge fan of the previous
spider-man franchise and she was excited
to get to represent the beautiful
diversity
in the real world through mj with the
rise of social media she also made sure
that her accounts were filled with
educational posts and even jokingly
called herself an african-american
history professor
it's not all about the selfies for
zendaya although we don't mind those
either
and you do not let people tell you what
you think you should feel
soon after her rendezvous with tom
holland she was cast in the greatest
showman
along with huge actors like hugh jackman
and zac efron
now this role a little more difficult to
step into compared to spider-man
if you've watched the award-winning
musical you know that zendaya spends a
lot of time
well swinging from things according to
insider she actually had to train to
perform the stunts herself
at a partner in the mix zac efron and
like he said
it didn't matter if we got it perfect a
lot of people had to get it perfect
she had to prep for stunt work acting
dancing and singing
i think it's safe to say she was
successful hugh jackman walked by i
think he goes into you
you're a badass next up the face of
cover girl
this career move didn't take much prep
from this a-lister
especially because covergirl is
basically on the same level as her when
it comes to promoting
inner beauty and diversity she even made
an entire instagram post about it
she actually is stunning inside and out
while starring in spider-man homecoming
its sequel
and the greatest showman was definitely
a huge jump from the zendaya we saw in
the disney channel
nothing could have prepared us for her
role in the drake produced series
euphoria
articles hit the web questioning if this
was finally zendaya's turn to the dark
side that would tarnish her perfectly
kept image
but it literally did the exact opposite
zendaya's fans have grown alongside her
and the actress felt it was time to move
on to a more mature scene
she knew she wanted more after she had
to return to disney to finish casey
undercover
when she read the script she knew if she
didn't accept the role she'd be
miserable
while she wasn't really sure how to
embody a character who was involved with
things like illegal substances
zendaya got to know sam who actually had
her on his mood board for her character
roo
getting to know him and his story made
her less nervous about taking on the
challenging role
now she's nominated for her first emmy
because of it killing it
but zendaya wants fans to know that
she's still into the corny stuff too
and hopes that she's living in a world
where she can take on both types of
characters
basically the best of both worlds are we
right
as of 2020 she's set to star in season 2
of euphoria was recently added to the
oscars voting board
has been cast in dune alongside fellow
rising star timothy chalmay
and there are rumors swirling that she
could be starring in a potential kill
bill 3.
as for her fashion career she was
recently featured on the cover of vogue
and released a fashion line in
collaboration
with tommy hilfiger maybe it was all
luck that zendaya was able to wiggle
herself into so many different
industries
or maybe it was because she always has a
clear vision of what she wanted to
achieve
if you truly believe in something and
you really have a passion for something
then go for it either way she's on track
to literally be the meryl streep of gen
z
let us know what your favorite part of
zendaya's transformation was in the
comment section below
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up and hit that subscribe button if you
want to see more videos on queen zendaya